I feel good about this the waiting area
is dark but you feel a presence Friday
[Music]
hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to stories untold now
we're on episode three and I'm not sure
what to expect anymore because the first
two were so drastically different that I
don't know where it's going with this
other one I know it's gonna be in the
same vein but I'm hoping it's gonna be
more true horror okay we're gonna speed
past this go it be gone thought ah the
good old stranger things were buff but
that's okay because the game is good if
the game was crap and be less forgiving
do you read me yeah I'm here
hey how's it going hello it's me your
best friend markiplier here I guess oh
come on watch the language man no need
to be so rude oh I see that flag out
there okay
login zero three zero three one Niner
six eight nice what took you is the
microphone still broken in Station three
take that convenient reply you should be
able to hear you though the activity
register so your voice is definitely
going through uh-huh okay we can chat
later three yeah this is pretty serious
I've had a distress call from central
there's a situation and we have to fire
up signal monitoring and relay systems
right away what kind of situations I
don't know
I'm assuming it's got something to do
with this storm whatever it is it's big
to want to involve us [ __ ] okay what do
we do then
well my [ __ ] cabin power isn't
holding up in this weather
so I can't process the signals myself
too you need to feed the frequency
information through to the backup
turbine or in station three and three
you just need to chain decode and
process just refer to the handbook on
the microfilm I'll walk you through it
I've never done any of this stuff so I'm
not gonna be much help I'm afraid it's
simple honestly you could do this in
your sleep okay first one is due to
appear in a minute or so have a quick
read of that microfilm handbook it
should be on your left yeah I'm gonna
get suited up and we started generating
[ __ ] it up Oh I'll try not to f it up
bro oh I'm I'm currently effing it up
because I'm more ending this completely
wrong way okay I I'm trying to how do
you what the hell okay it's up and down
okay okay what is that what do you what
is that Eagle Sun focused can't see it
there we go okay sis dot exe - f - why -
construe what oh oh FM k 1930 kilohertz
well this seems like an obsolete awfully
obscure thing that I need to do k input
broadcast authorization
hey abacus or abacus abacus oh into this
terminal and execute
what do you mean this terminal what are
you talking about this terminal I can't
enter anything into this terminal Oh
buzz Andy oh okay - D - E okay this is
convoluted but interesting
I'm not against thinking and using my
brain it's just when I do I kind of get
nosebleeds and my whole memories get a
race because in my head can you shut up
okay creepy sounding things over USB
okay got it
Chevron all right Chevron it is okay
Chevron is off it's all the way at the
end 20 oh [ __ ] I went too far
Chevron here we go okay ref in it WZ
okay
Proc begin shut up get integer X Y Z all
right that doesn't make much sense but
okay let's give that a go Oh what did I
do wrong
get in X Y Z get in X Y Z that's what it
is isn't it no that's what it is
get dot in X Y Z
Oh substituting any dynamic variables
okay so something goes in X Y Z but what
goes in X Y Z oh here we go where x
equals second fifth and sixth number
from the broadcast code Oh six one two
that's what it is six one two bang boom
baby huh oh yeah that's what I get for
not reading you know yeah yeah
what do you mean yeah no dos next one is
coming through with an additional note
GCS 3 equals e 1v 1 m1 I've not seen it
before
check the microfilm might be something
in there about it Melissa thing let me
know when you're done with that one I
haven't heard back from the transport
team I'm starting to worry
sure thing yeah okay here it is okay
that's different
crashing red screen yeah quite the
warning sign
something's going on the last three must
have just been testing the system treat
it as normal and I'll see what I can
find out once they get these damn lights
okay you grab Bubba oh no oh no zero
[Music]
nine zero nine seven seven two zero oh
three sorry three zero nope not three-30
this is what it is oh I didn't hit enter
correctly god damn it of course guy was
duh but I got it right so what was this
one I didn't even pay attention to it
Kansas Kansas love me some Kansas
everybody loves Kansas ok substituting
dynamic variables X is the largest
number from the original broadcast Y is
the smallest number from the original
broadcast smallest number which would be
0 oh I guess point dot pkg dot X which
is 9 and then Sal a4g okay all right
what did you want I'm about to head
outside to look at this generator no my
cabin is completely out don't do that
I just checked the roster and we were
supposed to hear from the supply team
three days ago
so I had nothing no responses either we
[ __ ] wait if dawn I hope three can you
monitor arrange for me they use an
emergency signal somewhere between eight
eight and a half thousand range fm see
if you can track it down for me that's
our supplies for the next six months if
they turn back what do we do we can
reschedule
wait don't worry that they didn't turn
back otherwise of the ebon a drink by
now the boat was called 20s
good yeah okay three eight eight and a
half thousand FM somewhere see if you
can pick up a distress signal or
something okay eight nine eight eight
and eight and a half thousand sure what
is being described as
further updates as they happen yes oh my
god hello distress signal from supply
but 2 0 F please respond I'm here but I
can't talk cuz mine's the only mic
that's broken what was that
mess with our GPS and straighten us is
he talking about we rolled up here
he's got word from central of New York
has fallen everyone's gone
I thought us being so remote give us
time
I can see it come be ready thank you for
being so vague
what are you that are you hearing this
lock your door two three do the same
what do you mean did you hear the report
just go call from station via the coast
something is happening I don't know what
but they said we had to lock up and stay
in our cabin then it went dead what are
you talking about just to do it
they're here thank you
equally is confused do we process this
don't yeah as long as the TCS number is
going up we're helping a lot of people
it was three last time it's six this
time what does it mean that's good
that's good just my process the Siddons
that's it in Sierra hotel Bravo
ah their call letters this time huh
my Sierra hotel
Bravo echo my Sierra what the hell is
that
how's that word
mic mic Zulu
oh wait a minute oh it's part of a table
oh the frequency okay the frequency is
six nine seven zero six nine seven zero
fifteen - fifteen - twenty three and six
okay three and six this should be it
come on are you kidding me oh god I was
looking at the wrong one 14 to 21 god
damn it there we go got it it was one up
from any other one a centaur
ah got a deal with all these mythical
creatures of lore there she is there she
is em status our command string Z each
grid W yeah ha ha okay I don't know what
this Sol scorched-earth thing was last
time but it seemed pretty bad I can see
something about threes cabin one of the
power lines down
hmm [ __ ] what the hell is that I cannot
see you from here one what's going on
it's about me [ __ ] it's above me it's
over station three - they're here what's
here Jesus one what the [ __ ] is out
there it's fine it's fine you'll be fine
oh yeah yeah and now you're offline yeah
totally fine [ __ ]
here's another signal GC and seven
equals e 1v v m11 what the hell it's
laughing urgent okay I guess I'm just
doing this sacrifice Oh what did that
say at the bottom wait
this is a live scenario urgent this is a
live scenario okay all right sure
that's crazy
you'll get yourself killed no died
you're seeing things for four week
where did four come from okay wrote X X
actuate Y point one Z X is 1 2 & 3 from
the original broadcast author Asian word
from pendeks see I wasn't planning to
point one Z okay guys
I'm shutting down station five and
getting the [ __ ] out of here they took
it out of the ground oh here we go
code word Jesus what is this oh my god
okay signal modulation oh geez um's okay
USB
holy crap broadcast frequency 8150
process total number of broadcast
numbers okay now here we go
[Music]
18:02 27 27 let Alexander okay okay and
then this other one for sacrifice let's
try this here we go
oh god that was a pain but I did it so
that's good all launched I don't know
what we're launching but it can't be too
good my terminal is going crazy
demanding a response I think the wind is
misaligned a transmitter or something we
need to go no wait hang on now now I
thank you see I'm sorry but I can't get
out I'm trapped you'll still be able to
hear me though go go
oh oh oh okay I guess I'm out here now
I don't mind me having a good time in
the cold oh boy yes good oh oh oh and
now I'm alright now I'm outside sure
yeah okay yeah we're gonna all right you
know this is fine yep is fine this is
definitely fine let's go outside
okay this bad oh it's very bad okay I
got a bad feeling something's about to
jump out of me in any moment here
literally any moment death could be
crawling up my butthole any moment death
could be crawling up my butthole right
okay also where were these other guys
and why did I only hear about four five
and six after one had died probably if
one was outside and or one did get
dragged outside and also something just
dragged me outside and I'm just
wandering as if nothing is a problem I
don't know where I'm going in if someone
could try to point me in the right
direction could you need more numbers to
process that'd be great that'd be real
good they couldn't have made this base
any more convoluted I just go to big
circle did I just go to big circle this
is where I started what are those pipes
where's the Alaskan pipeline
alright fine then sure keep your secrets
Oh what is this oh I'm making my way
around town so I can climb up this
[ __ ] okay cuz this is what I gotta do
I gotta manually align this bad boy okay
and what have we got here yeah okay
nothing there those that didn't help at
all I guess um uh here knock knock
well here whoa
the old generator trick because so I
need another power monster yeah they
couldn't have put the generators
anywhere near the thing they needed a
big powered the station for hay far can
you let me in this guy's uh tip bit
nipply out here it's just a little cold
just a little on the cold side if you
didn't mind maybe helping me out a
little bit no okay I'll just be on my
way then
and three two one kaboom kaboom kaboom
whoa
that seems good what is birds doing here
don't know I was a foghorn but okay did
I do it what do I go back what wait wait
wait okay that's not right that's that's
the opposite of right I have no idea
what's happening radio towers work well
who's whispering in my ear seems like I
might be going a little bit crazy
maybe reality isn't exactly what I think
it is who's coming back
is it me am i coming back cuz it seemed
to be coming back now
is it me might be me
need to wake up huh wake up am I in a
coma
is this a coma this might be a coma
oh oh oh wow
[Music]
yeah welcome back that was that was the
inside inside it was the same layout as
in the first chapter right who was the
same layout it was the same layout it
was the same one the same layout as the
first one it had the desk lamp I saw it
the old-style computer monitor I saw it
I have no idea what's happening here but
we are about to finish it all right
chapter 4 the last session interesting
like that last one it started so slow
with all the puzzle thing yeah it was so
slow you can escape it anytime to get
help I don't know what that means no no
no you mean by that a skip skip skip
I think that's enough of that for now
yeah I agree I agree I'm quite fond of
the show Anya oh yeah you know I like it
it's pretty neat who are you okay come
on let's get you down to the observation
room oh I don't like the sound of the
observation oh I'm being wheeled I don't
have a choice in the matter do I sounds
awfully busy starting to feel like home
to you gotta open up don't worry
try and get you out of here eventually
oh just in here
I don't like this observation room it's
our baby how we threw in an extra just
relax and we'll get started in a moment
right goodbye
creepy guy who's locked me in here with
a cassette tape and a camera all right
the station now are you ready sure just
hit record on the tape deck in front of
you when you're ready okay
click I'm ready baby born really kicked
12 1986 23 new session entry we have
myself alexander leading and in a room
we have our patient mr. James Asian
mm-hmm as we know James has recently
recovered from a two-week coma following
his accident in our last three sessions
James has attempted to recollect events
of the accident seen him merging his
memory with his imagination the episodes
have always ended in panic and we've had
to terminate the session abruptly let's
try and do this one better James okay
but when you're ready oh so I know I've
ready must be but you can't do this
James
it's time to remember okay I'm so ready
to remember rememberings like my
favorite thing who is that your mind
Oh like a conscious black box
Oh show you your memories
like a conscious black box you say okay
all right so long existing jabs a needle
in my I know everything will be alright
whoa
okay well that was something in your
most recent episode you recalled a false
memory of a remote weather station
you're isolated from the rest of the
world locked inside you coma we
interacted with you daily encouraging
you to make your family would do number
puzzles with you anything really to
bring back people needed answers James
do you remember I have another signal
here for you James it's a five six one
zero fm
okay
five six type in the numbers James 12 19
6:23 zero
type report wait what is this whoa wait
a minute
traffic accident fatal accident one
injured oh I got in a car accident empty
whiskey out of control Sudan
oh so the other guy the other guy was
drunk
oh no yeah the driver was an ex-police
officer of twenty years I had my sister
in the car with me
weird what the hell it must be the
circled things okay 20 F dash fatal
accident and then empty whiskey and out
of control okay that's got to be it out
of control I think we used to go to the
back where it's always right okay 7000
fm you got it baby
nothing seesee it's not like at all I've
worked with officer Henning for six
years and not once have we even talked
about alcohol drunk driving
he was a father a husband was fine no
way he caused this if him this Haitian
guy he's got something to hide this
doesn't make sense to you
no it doesn't uh step out into the
hospital ward only it seems abandoned
your vision is blurry oh I see under
stress keep a healthy mind time to quit
help is here
ah okay driving home don't have that
fifth pint fifth I'm fifth timed four
pints and you're good to drive okay you
tense up someone else is here who's here
in this hospital that probably has a lot
of people in there hello who's there
who's there is something there that I
should know
I did Lee ho you grabbed the keys from
the table that way heavy in your hand
they're also bleeding they feel really
grimy you spend most waking moments in
air the only video they have some more
accomplishing trash that doesn't sound
good
you only caught a glimpse of the room
you guess that's why there is no detail
here Oh cuz it's a memory I see okay
yeah
another door you never opened you don't
know what was in here okay I feel good
about this the waiting area is dark but
you feel a presence right behind right
you tricked me that's my trick someone
breathe is on your neck standing over a
hill
alright okay well whoever standing right
over a Oriole literally watching you
from the shadows a robber they are going
to be in for a treat you feel dread in
the pit of your stomach
I sure do don't I oh that's bright what
okay we have our 22 year old male just
brought in from the vehicle collision he
was awake in mobile at the scene but
collapsed on arrival to the emergency
ward the other passengers died in the
accident
Oh getting no pulse prepare for defib
amp charge full to ten and give me 100
joules
oh come on hundred joules charge up food
Oh hundred joules do you got it baby
hundred joules ah here we go
can we get this on the screen please you
got it it's on the screen right now
okay maybe not well there we go hello hi
oh that's not good
caboose key oh wow reaction from first
stage
let's try higher 200 joules keep the amp
charge to 10 you got it baby the charge
of 10 let's go let's go
kaboom didn't know I have to do this to
myself here weak signal uh-huh
let's keep going increase again 360
charge cool charging come on 360 hurry
Bob
well did you look at that seems we have
a pulse uh-huh rhythm is stable we need
to run an x-ray right away okay x-ray
you got it
I don't remember how to do the x-ray oh
that was it now was it okay what do we
got how many broken bones like an
intracerebral hemorrhage we need to
drain this now to relieve pressure train
my brain Oh
switch on the drill please oh no oh boy
okay all right um yeah sure the drill
please oh it's oh it's on baby no it is
it is on oh okay we didn't need to see
the x-ray okay I gotcha
like where we go Hugh
we're going to attempt to alleviate the
discomfort
[Music]
oh why would you do that to me oh hey
how you doing hey how's it going okay
back to the beginning and in many ways
my favorite not only its nanang New
Year's Eve but tomorrow you leave on a
six-month trip abroad with friends mom
dad and your sister Jennifer has decided
to throw a party to celebrate it all the
house is full you're in the living room
and as usual you don't recognize a
single soul look around the room is full
of chatty strangers mostly friends of
mom and dad this door to the hall you
exchanged pleasantries knot and smile
nod and smile leave you push through the
crowd into the hallway the hallway is as
welcoming as ever
only this time the folks have put a
great big banner up across the main hall
half finished drinks are abandoned on
almost every horizontal surface stairs
lead up although the party is firmly
downstairs grounds same as ever stairs
door deliveryman door the kitchen
kitchen they say all the best parties
are in the kitchen that they do the
kitchen is full of people and loud their
drinks and food on the table and the
party is in full swing
dad has cooked a hog roast which sits
proudly on the table although known as
eating it eat hog maybe later
look around there's a utility room and
writing on the wall also Jenna's here
signaling you okay read writing happy
new year 1986 on another banner weird
place to hang it okay talk to Jennifer
she's too far away and the room is too
loud go to Jennifer he pushed through
apologizing over and over to get to
Jennifer you hug you're going to miss
each other you thank her for the party
she asked if you're enjoying the party
um no you tell her you're not having fun
she frowns well too bad she tells you to
enjoy it anyway into loosen up she asked
you to get her a drink okay where is a
drink
you poor Janet drank and one for
yourself too it's never an awkward
silence with Jennifer she always has a
question she asked if you have
everything sorted for the big trip
yeppers peppers she repeats herself yes
you tell her yes that you have packed
everything with plenty of room to spare
another hug your family have really gone
out of their way to make this trip
happen for you it might be what you need
to get some perspective and maybe not
[ __ ] up so much she's gonna miss you
you're gonna miss her she walks away
Janice disappeared into the crowd you're
left standing nodding and smiling at the
approving faces there's so much to do
for this move can't mess it up but first
a drink drink pouring down another drink
anything to move the night along enter
closet open door open the door and peer
in you're never allowed in here normally
this is where dad keeps his fine wines
and whiskeys ceiling to floor racks a
collector although he does actually
drink them too there's a bottle with a
ribbon round it and a card a good bottle
so gift from dad I think there's a card
next to it read card you pick up the
whisky and the card it's your dad's
handwriting son we're so proud of you
and everything you've achieved you've
earned this it's a bottle of 25 year old
double malt you shouldn't really but you
have to try it with your whiskey and an
you take in the room around you there
must be hundreds now thousands of pounds
of worth of drink in here you really
must thank your dad for the whiskey
leave you head back into the kitchen
clutching your new best friend you
stumble out of the utility room and back
into the kitchen that is one strong
whiskey you take another swig and give a
thumbs up to dad across the room he nods
and winks talk to dad he tells you he's
proud of you and to go easy tonight
early flight tomorrow hog dad Oh Maura
we've a few bumps and laughs on the way
through it and you make it to the hall
you stop dead in your tracks it's Jen
covered in blood
she's staring straight at you no one
else notices blood is dripping down her
face is mixing with tears
I'm sorry I don't understand I'm sorry I
don't understand I'm sorry I don't
understand mrs. ation of her injuries
were too severe just talking to her
I'm afraid Jennifer passed away before
we could get to her in surgery we did
the best we could I'm so sorry
let me see her thanks miss sensation
take a seat I don't want to take a seat
let me talk to her
no I'll arrange for you to see her in
the meantime James is in recovery he's
stable for I don't want to see him
you're standing in the hallway something
to stop you in your tracks while
searching your mind your sister
interrupts she waved her hand in front
of you and asks if you can drive her
home you still feel out of sorts those
words echo yeah yeah we can talk in the
car go get your keys
I can't drive okay look around doors the
kitchen and living room lead from your
wall stairs can take you up go upstairs
you'd love to call it a night but jen is
waiting patiently she's waiting
patiently for their ride home you
promised her Oh No assure your keys are
in the living room the living room is a
much more relaxed atmosphere compared to
the kitchen various guests are sat on
the chairs having civilized
conversations there's a coffee table in
the middle of the room your mom is
pouring a drink at the drinks cabinet
talk to Mum tears immediately start to
appear in her eye my son off to America
she gives you a hug you need to look for
them they must be either in the kitchen
or the living room your mum's collection
wines the spirits definitely no keys in
here
alright empty-handed you head back into
the hall maybe your keys are in the
kitchen I know where this is going the
kitchen is busy way too many people
crammed in here but I guess this is
where the food and drink are at the
guests are like a set of vultures
picking at the roast on the kitchen
counter your dad is locking up the
utility room look around it's difficult
to move around in here between all the
people in the kitchen table the table is
a mess party food mixed unclaimed drinks
use napkins no keys though dad tells you
to take your sister home but to go slow
since you've had a few drinks already no
way son I think you've had enough of my
hard-earned collection you head back out
the hallway you're standing back in the
hallway bottle of whiskey in hand but no
car keys 10 points the living room in
size as she puts on her coat I was just
in there
you sure keys are in the living room I
was just in there
you take a look underneath no keys oh I
thought that would have been it look
under table take a look underneath look
under coats you look underneath you
search throughout the jackets of coats
until you find yours aha car keys in the
pocket you grab both all right easy keys
and an you head back into the hall I
mean not that this is good maybe it
would have been better if I never found
her she has work in the morning and no
one else is any fit state it's a drive
you can handle it though you know the
road like the back of your hand don't
you I don't know yes okay let's go
you open the front door and walk out
into the freezing night cold air hits
you you're glad you have your jacket
with you there's a dusting of snow
around you as you step down from the
porch the yard extends around the back
of the house and the car sits at the
front of the house oh go around house
just get Jen home then you can get back
to the party all right
enter car you fumble with the key car
handle confused until Jen tells you that
maybe use the key in your hand unlock
door you'll get the door up and climb
inside all right oh boy the car is
freezing as you fumble around with your
seat belt your sister opens up the car
glove box and hand you a note and key
that was inside she tells you that is
for when you return a notice from your
dad and reads hi son hope you enjoy your
break you'll need to fire up the
generator around the back to get power
and lights on also found something in
the Attic for you what's in your room
and joy yeah all right start are you
tried to turn the ignition with sheer
willpower but hold me despite holding
the keys in what keys in ignition you
smart ass takes a number of attempts but
you eventually slot the key in the
ignition starts car the car squeals but
stays stationary uh release brake it
really does seem like I'm very drunk
shift put car in gear change
here dry put the car in gear ah that one
you're not gonna make me to a specific
you shouldn't really really shouldn't be
driving yeah you I am driving very drunk
yeah Jen starts dozing off as soon as
the journey got goin this shouldn't take
long you come to a Junkin is it left or
right you can't remember I'm gonna go
with the right I'm sorry I don't
understand left look around the road
goes off to the left and right you can't
remember which way to go
the roads are quiet always you don't
want to but you had better ask Jen for
directions she grunts and throws her arm
to the left it's left of course it's
left you turn the car left at the
junction and accelerate off confident
that you are on the right road now you
loosen up and put your foot down on the
accelerator you feel powerful as the
engine roars at your command
Jen sits up in clusters at your arms yes
you slow down slow down
that's not what really happened though
is it you try to react but your body
isn't responding there's nothing you can
do to stop this there's no way to
control it the lights merged with your
car the outside joins the inside the
whole world
it was at this very moment wasn't it
James the moment you lost it all your
sister the parents yourself and then you
made it worse
[Music]
you wake up in the car your world is
upside down your seat belt struggles
against gravity trying to hold you in
your seat and impact into another car is
torn a hole in the chassis poisonous
fumes spill into your car from the
engines you're in grave danger do you
have to get out of here you can't move
your seatbelt is still in place you
release yourself from the seat gravity
takes over as you slump onto the roof of
the car you squeeze through the wreckage
and fall to your knees on the ground
next to your vehicle every breath brings
pain to your chest your head is
throbbing a blue car is smashed into the
passenger side of your car your life
cannot be ruined by this you're standing
holding your whiskey and dad's note and
flashing lights are approaching at a
distance
a crash site smoke billows from the
crash cars to the sky above exterior
lights flicking on and off the note
always changing now reads get through
this James I don't care if you want to
or not
or whiskey blue car with the lights
approaching closer you begin to hear the
shrill at their sirens you simply cannot
go to jail for this you clean the bottle
to remove your connection with the
whiskey and you then very deliberately
spill the remainder of the bottles
contents on the driver and you toss the
incriminating evidence onto his
passenger seat a circle of flashing
lights around you illuminating the crash
set in the darkness behind them an army
of people all staring one figure steps
out silhouette who walks towards you
silhouette is a police officer and in
uniform he beckons you to approach he
try to talk but you are not making any
sense as you approach the man the
pulsating lights around you get dimmer
and dimmer while the pain in your head
increases you fall to the ground at his
feet
but no matter what you keep telling
yourself you have to listen to me
that accident
me you have to remember
it was all your fault
I know that II did have you left me
there to protect yourself planting
evidence on
we went headfirst into that opposite and
wrecked all of our lives
[Music]
you couldn't even take responsibility
you did the right thing for you and no
one else to save yourself only it really
wasn't
okay we concede
say it James
[Music]
doctors
all of your episodes were recorded to
tape this is the fourth time James
understand
[Music]
sometimes they make you watch your past
sessions to see what really happened
[Music]
well I think we've made progress today
mr. Asian I guess we should tell the
police what you've told us although I
don't suspect I'll take you anywhere I
think you'll be with us for quite some
time
come on let's get you back to your shows
I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
okay um that was that was awesome what a
grim story but I love it I love that it
commits to the grimness of it
oh the character isn't someone who
deserves Redemption he's going through
hell and it kind of deserves it oh it's
so crazy it all makes sense in a weird
way god that's insane it set it up from
the very beginning and I love that such
a unique way to tell a story who's so
fun that was so fun those insanity I
love that it was so good goddamn that
was good I love that this unbelief fight
I love that oh my god makes so much
sense now I should have turned on
subtitles I didn't have subtitles on
from the beginning god damn it that
would have been very helpful well
there's nothing else to say besides wow
this was a great game I loved this if
you want to play this for yourself I'll
put a link in the description below but
thank you everybody so much for watching
watch out for that thing that's standing
right behind you and just thank you this
was a really cool experience let me know
if you've got more cool scary games like
this for me to play in the comments down
below because this one came out like
over a year ago and somehow slipped
under my radar and I loved it so thank
you everybody so much for watching if
you want to see more scary games that
I've played I'll provide a link in the
description below or you can go to the
scary games playlist where I've got
hundreds and hundreds of scary games
that I've played so thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]